lorsqu'il s'agit de commerce
international la langue de bois des
dirigeants des grandes puissances est
souvent dénoncée par de nombreuses ong
soucieuse du climat aujourd'hui elles
sont 40 à interpeller emmanuel macron
sur les conséquences désastreuses
qu'aurait selon elle l'accord entre l'ue
et les états du mercosur en matière de
climat de biodiversité et de droits
humains
ces ong font également part de leur
incompréhension quant aux nombreuses
déclarations d' emmanuel macron depuis
son élection en 2017
pour les signataires de cette tribune le
fameuse est retentissant à l'époque mais
quand planète doit et le guen du
président de la république après la
décision de donald trump de se retirer
des accords de paris n'était finalement
que de la poudre aux yeux
lors du g20 osaka en 2019 emmanuel
macron avait assuré devant les caméras
que la france ne conclurait pas d'accord
avec des états qui ne respecte pas ses
engagements en terme de biodiversité
il avait réitéré ses propos quelques
semaines plus tard lors du g7 à biarritz
en insistant sur le fait que la france
ne signeraient pas l'accord entre l'ue
et les états d'amérique latine
il faut rappeler que l'amazone y était
alors en train de brûler emmanuel macron
avait même admis que la france avait une
part de complicité dans les incendies en
raison de la dépendance de notre pays au
soja brésilien en partie responsable de
la déforestation de l'amazonie
sur ces paroles prometteuse pourrait-on
croire finalement le 2 juillet 2020 les
accords entre l'ue et le mercosur ont
été finalisés eh oui dans leur tribune
les ong se dit scandalisée que croire
c'est à n'y rien comprendre fin de
citation en réalité il n'y a pas grand
chose à comprendre sous la pression
commercial colossal à laquelle sont
soumis les états dans un monde basé sur
la croissance à tout prix même les âmes
les plus charitables finissent par céder
et on parle même pas des as moins
charitable
est il nécessaire de rappeler que
parallèlement aux grands débats sur le
climat qui font la une des médias du
monde entier depuis quelques années des
accords commerciaux titanesque ont été
signés entre états malgré la
désapprobation de centaines de lg tirant
la sonnette d'alarmé
l'accord de libre échange entre l'ue et
le vietnam vient par exemple d'entrer en
vigueur le mois dernier il prévoit de
mettre fin à la quasi totalité des
droits de douane entre les deux parties
dans les dix ans à venir et ce
malgré la colère des ong et de
personnalités qui dénoncent son coût
écologique et sa mauvaise influence sur
la situation des droits humains dans ce
pays d'asie du sud est
même son de cloche avec singapour en
février 2019
pareil avec le japon la même année et
bien évidemment le fameux c'est à entre
l'ue et le canada déjà provisoirement
appliquer depuis septembre 2017
malgré les manifestations les pétitions
les tribunes contre cet accord on peut
protester autant qu'on veut brandir la
bannière de la défense du climat aux
quatre coins de la planète s'émouvoir de
la situation écologique mondiale
désastreuse
business is business l'accord entre l'ue
et le mercosur ne fait que le confirmer
en attendant on pourra toujours lutté
pour la biodiversité en supprimant les
tout y est en plastique à la cafétéria
ou le sapin de noël en centre ville